we
interrupt this program to bring you an
extremely irrelevant album
that i co-created with no
not that album this album i co-created
at the age of 10 years old
and has never been heard by anyone
apart from a couple of people so why did
i create this album
and is it any good to find out we must
rewind back to
the past and ask my friend amy
this is what happens when we're not
allowed on the internet hi guys
today i'm here with my friend amy
and we're gonna check out my first ever
album and you guys
don't even know about it another do you
no i've never heard of it
so when i was in primary school i had
one friend and we made music together we
used to do covers we've got a cover of
britney spears on there somewhere
but we also used to write original music
as well interesting
her main part of it was to beatbox
because we didn't
yeah she beatbox because we didn't we
didn't play any instruments the name
of our band was uh the busted fans
very original this is exclusive
jagman x the busted fans
not the best quality but it'll sound
vintage
yeah it'll sound vintage
we are the busted fans
and this is our album
i hope you like it and first
here's a little song made up
called busted
it's called bastard
oi
oh
[Music]
and that was it
[Music]
i'm bored well you should come to
woodlands
why you can do whatever you want
like throw your rubbish on the floor but
again
let's go to woodlands okay okay i've
just come back from woodlands it was
brilliant
one go when i'm walking down the street
everybody
that i meet i know that they're talking
about me
i know that because i see them stepping
straight back at me
i wonder if they're calling me a dirty
breath
she has the word and everything
well if i can nothing she has
well and everything
one if i can nothing run by god nothing
wanna backyard
[Music]
i can't tell if it's the cassette that's
making me squeaky or if i was actually
nothing no i think you were squeaky
now we are going to sing are you sure
ready are you sure you forgive me
after
[Music]
[Music]
cause
are you sure
oh my god now we are going to sing
beep i hate it
baby
oh
[Music]
and then
[Music]
we just got off the tv
at aster today you can get some oranges
for 55p a
bunch a bunch i just don't come on
bunches
so
[Music]
song make up tomorrow yeah this is our
song about tomorrow
[Music]
pizza and chips
[Music]
ah
sounds like a big strike
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know why teenagers
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
the world
[Music]
[Music]
came and it flew down the lane
conservation constipation
the windscreen of the car and the
milkshake by constipation
concentration
where's the rest
i went to the loot to have a poo
conservation conservation i screamed and
shout but i couldn't get it out
conservation
conservation i'd call for mum she's like
a hand up about constipation
consummation
out it came and it flew down being
constipation conservation did a man in
the face on an understated case
conservation
conservation hit the risk of a car and a
milkshake by conservation conservation
and this was my life boom boom boom
obviously
[Music]
the game shop implement is soon moving
to tavistock
so we're making all the game prizes
half price it sims for 299
supreme pop welfare 250p
come along to game at fart moves to top
stock and that will all be gone and you
can get the really really good packages
of games you're toxic
i'm sipping on the taste of the boys in
paradise
and i love what you do don't you know
what's toxic
intoxicate me now with your love now i
think i'm ready now
i think i'm ready now i'm talking now
with 11 now i think i'm ready
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
like that yeah
[Music]
[Music]
and i was like please i just want to
sing just do some
[Music]
because we were either singing or we
were making videos together
[Music]
[Music]
i know these apps i know these i'm gonna
pair you up
jump everyone take my kisses in the
night bed
when you are next to me
[Music]
[Music]
oh so right
jump for my love
[Music]
why
are you tired of having a silent
treatment well you should come to
help us it helped you not get the silent
treatment from your friends
so this will now be this
as well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
she was like we never played with henzel
i know but it rhymes
we go to different schools secondary
school
i wrote this set for how many people's
[Music]
why aren't we friends anymore i think
this is the reason
yeah this is definitely the reason i'm
sorry
so you had to put up with me now you
have to put up with me
yeah but i don't make you sing with me
so it's okay oh yeah
no yet that's the next album
here
[Music]
you could definitely replace you
whatever
singing
[Music]
what do you think of my first album i
think your next album will be better
better um quality as well yeah yeah
no covers no covers no covers
no um yeah no beatboxes i think you
should definitely do
the toxic
oh my gosh no that's so funny though i'm
so embarrassed
i'm surprised at what you sound like so
you don't sound like yourself
at all i know but it's like it's quite
cool to look back at that though because
i'm like i'm still
doing me yeah like back then literally
we used to just
do songs like adverts and stuff we used
to she used to have a little camcorder
and we used to like make her own like
films and videos and
stuff and i'm still doing that now so
i'm still carrying on my legacy i
haven't seen her in so long if you're
watching which is probably not
probably forgotten but hi miss you
get in touch okay
have a lovely day or evening bye
she had the world bum bum bum bum and
everything
what have i got nothing oh
i know
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
when she's
[Music]
i had some nudes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
time
[Music]
[Music]
where am i going with it why am i
talking to god
oh i've died i won't be in hell
i won't be home in time for team
different priorities oh it's not
finished
he gave me my own palette i had a great
big kiss
[Music]